normal mondiale avec son opéra rock
mondialistes façon star du rhin
tiers-mondiste humaniste sur la sellette
dans l'une est la charité à l'interview
vérité
michel verjux bonsoir avant de parler
pour nouveau 33 tours on va parler de
starmania en urss pour commencer on ça
s'est passé comment le les premiers
jours j'ai vu les premiers spectacles
c'est très émouvant ce que c'est les
gens qui ont besoin de spectacle
incroyablement et qui sont cédés cela
d'envoyer vers livrer c'est vrai il y
avait un livre en russe les avait un
petit programme ont leur expliquer le
sujet moi j'ai pu parler à des jeunes
après parler un peu français et ils ont
une affection très assez extraordinaire
son pouvoir général janvier ça n'a pas
dû beaucoup les ethnies les ans jusqu'en
mai
non mais c'est elle qui m'a dit c'est et
ça lui rappelait son chef de bureau
le qatar - un dictateur un p c'était le
point de pouvoir de l'un par rapport à
l'autre c'est quelque chose qui est très
important pour l'instant là et c'est
vrai qu'ils ont applaudi seulement la
faim qu'ils ont pas osé réagir comme un
spectacle réussi peut-être est-ce la
changeant le web 1 avait assez peur
pendant le spectacle seront obligés
peut-être que ça leur plaît pas du tout
et ça a explosé à la fin c'était cet
effort va me rendre mon enfant alors
maintenant starmania et vendu à tim rice
créateur de jésus christ superstar et
d'évita donc on va le voir à londres sur
ses habits social linkedin live à faire
les tests c'est moi c'est quelqu'un pour
lequel j'ai beaucoup d'admiration c'est
une des raisons pour lesquelles un xp
risques de tapis dit qu'on sait des
choses qui leur tête
ça représente quelque chose pour nous
banquiers de faire genre après tu vas
faire une autre comédie musicale que tu
es en train d'écrire là la légende de
jimmy wales avec l'abandon jusqu'à
l'arrivée en échange c'est pas mal ouais
y'a diane tell qui choisissez sur ce
lien
c'est quoi l'histoire c'est pas un peu
rétro diaby toulalan sa saisine aurait
pas du tout genting sémite
le muc de la célébrité de l'adolescence
graphiquement dans les années 90 c'est
un jeune type qui comprend pas pourquoi
il est pas de gêne pas c'est notre cas
c'est particulier de décaler oui je
crois que ses inspecteurs sur
l'adolescence on va le voir quand ça
commence le 22 septembre à mogador c'est
fini ben c'est justement ça devrait
l'être dans mon dos et j'ai toujours
achopper quand même non paris va le
faire bosser de du mal non un bon
maintenant je crois qu'il sait que s'il
faut aller là c'est qu'ils fouillaient
la maison au canada à côté de chez lui
pour le surveiller c'est au tour du
monde
bon alors le nouveau 33 ça ne tient pas
debout à 50 est parfaite dit pourquoi
parce que je me trouvais
depuis quand il cause et non mais c'est
qu'il faut que ce soit un besoin et
c'était vraiment devenu un besoin qui
dit je ferai rien donc ce sera pas
quelque chose donc je serais pas capable
de faire quelque chose d'entièrement
différent de ce que j'ai fait auparavant
bon jusqu'ici quoi s en servant disent
oui moi j'ai la route elle discute
jamais pareil j'aime bien mais aussi en
matière monétaire
oh
3 pour les gens de toute manière tout ce
que je ferai tout le thalys sera pareil
sur certaine manière tellement phénomène
celle-ci charge et voilà mais pour moins
pour moi c'est une évolution énorme
ah ouais parce que j'ai d'abord
musiciens qui travaillent et j'aurais
sans doute jamais de travail avec yaël
notre époque c'est une mission de new
york très violent chez nord 20 noeuds
tout ça est une espèce d'énergie très
très dur que je voulais avoir à produire
des textes et puis en même temps de
détresse des maquis tu sais je crois que
c'est peut-être que pour moi que c'est
vraiment tout à fait différent et c'est
ça qui compte
en fait ce qui compte c'est de voir
absolument fascinant c'est vraiment dur